when people want to express the need for
liberty I think that art can be a most
sublime tool i'm rebecca alban hofburger
and the director and founder here at the
american visionary art museum in
Baltimore's Inner Harbor life liberty
and pursuit of happiness was intended I
when I picked the theme to be a communal
exploration of those words that get used
a lot and flag way a lot but perhaps not
thought about quite them at acquit ly in
terms of what do individuals really
think about that visionary art comes
from individuals who have not been
trained not poured through the filter of
anybody else's thoughts our favorite
visionary artists may not even think of
themselves as artists they just may be
driven to build the Garden of Eden in
their backyard for the next 40 years and
they're not looking to get shows in New
York or that kind of thing it's a very
deep personal
kind of expression and as dubuffet said
it's best when it forgets its very name
I find it more inspirational and driven
sometimes it's when the life experience
is too big for words either an
experience of ecstasy or an experience
that's so devastating that you can't
even put it express it otherwise other
than to take some action and that's when
its strongest in the show one of my
favorite artists is dr. alaba shear who
was the most gifted physician in Iraq at
reattaching limbs and at burn victims
and being in a war situation he had a
lot of practice he was also an artist
very refined beautiful man and he had
the terrible thing happened because it
was the best doctor where sanam Hussain
as the head of the country said hey
forget everybody else I want you to be
my personal doctor and he said it was
like living on the edge of a sword I
mean whenever you have to work for
someone who has a disproportionate
amount of authority it's not a great
thing you can see the caged figure with
the bird the bird is often wing things
are often used as a symbol for the human
soul and you see the loss of limbs the
inability to to in a great transcendent
of any individual language you know art
can speak to what it is to feel that you
have no arms and legs and you have this
soul that's imprisoned in your chest and
all that you normally would have to
express yourself has been truncated and
he said something very beautiful as
people said oh so you're a surreal is
paint around you know and he said no I'm
not surrealist painting painters were
painting their imagination he says I'm
not painting my imagination I'm painting
the real suffering of the men in the
women the children who were on
in this very long more what this museum
is about is what it is to the full
spectrum of what it is to be a human
being and sometimes the labeling of
mental patient or disabled or the very
real physical limitation whether it's a
thought disorder which keeps you from
focusing being you know bipolar or
schizophrenia there's often another
thing to be another quality to be mind
that is of great interest to others I
always love it when oscar levant said
there's a thin line between genius and
insanity and I've managed to erase it
you know you you want people who dance
at the border and at the edge because
then there they are evolutionary's they
are not trotting in the same safe but
they have gone to the edge to report
there's an artist named dick lubinski
who indeed had a history of
schizophrenia and who had like the
Collyer brothers syndrome you know we
never throw anything away and all the
trash mounts up to your ceiling and you
use a broom handle to turn on your
lights which kind of thing and when he
was ill and dying his niece visited him
and he says when you get when you wade
through the garbage after I'm dead
there's some good cameras in there and
you know you can sell them and I think
they'll bring you some money he never
brought up that he made always on social
justice I think the most exquisite
images in the whole show
and so that's a privilege to say is this
a diseased mind and yet his depiction of
the scottsboro boys who were wrongfully
accused of rape is so tenderly and
masterfully brought that it's an awesome
piece of art I'm not a person who says
gee art is always good because actually
like sex like money like political power
art is just one of the great powers that
can be misused you know sex can be one
of the most healing and ennobling and
loving of acts and it could be the most
devastating hurtful demeaning violent
cruel act it's not within itself either
good or bad and I believe that that's
true with art and transcending even this
notion of good or bad it is a power and
so when people want to express the need
for liberty I think that art can be a
most sublime tool because it speaks in
in a language that can be visually read
by all different languages etc I wanted
a place that would be like a grassroots
salon that would tack
all the great themes that have ever been
deviled or inspired humankind and that
the art that would be wrestling with
those issues would likewise come for
people who think their own thoughts it's
very rare for anybody to think of fresh
thought you go to a cocktail party in
someone you know hates Hillary Clinton
or they really like her but you don't
really hear something that makes you oh
my god I never thought about that and
this is a museum dedicated to fresh
thought in all of its permutations